[Music]
Okay. Hi everyone. Welcome to the
conference. How you doing?
Excellent. Usually I open these
conferences with a small little talk to
introduce uh you know what's going on
and then give you a little update on
where the state of AI engineering is and
how we put together the conference for
you. Uh this is a this is one of those
combined talks. I'm trying to answer
every single question you have about the
conference about AI news about where
this is all going and we'll just dive
right in. Okay. So um 3,000 of you all
of you registered last minute. Uh thank
you for that stress. Um I actually can
quantify this. I call this the genie
coefficient for uh the AI AIE organizer
stress. Uh this is compared to last
year. Uh it is please just buy tickets
earlier like I mean you know you're
going to come just just do it. Okay. Um
we also uh like to use this conference
as a way to track the evolution of AI
engineering. Uh that's those are the
tracks for last year. We've just doubled
every single track for you. Um so
basically it's basically you know like
double the value for whatever you uh get
here and I think like uh I think this is
as much concurrency as we want to do
like I know I I hear that people have
decision fatigue and all that uh totally
but also we try to cover all of AI so
deal with it.
Um we also pride ourselves in doing well
by being more responsive than other
conferences like Europe's and being more
technical than other conferences uh like
TED or whatever what have you. So we
asked you what you wanted to hear about.
These are the surveys. Uh we tried all
sorts of things. We tried computer using
agents. We tried AI and crypto. It's
always a fun one. And uh but you guys
told told us what you wanted and we put
it in there. Um for all for more data um
we would actually like you to to finish
out our survey where survey is not done.
So if you want to head to that URL um we
will present the results in full
tomorrow. We would love all of you to to
fill it out so we can get a
representative sample of what you want
and uh that will inform us next year.
Okay. Um you know I think the other
thing about AI engineering is that we
also have been innovating as engineers
right we we're the first conference to
have an MCP. at our first conference to
have an MCP talk accepted by MCP
where shout out to Sam Julian from
Writer for working with us on the
official chatbot and Quinn and John from
Daily for working with us on the
official voice bot as well as Elizabeth
Triken from uh Vappy. I need to give her
a shout out because she originally uh
helped us uh prototype uh the the voice
bot as well. So we're trying to
constantly improve the experience.
Uh the other thing I think I want to
emphasize as well is like these are the
talks that I give like in 2023
uh the very first AIE I talked about the
uh the three types of AI engineer in
2024 I talked about um how AI
engineering was becoming more multi
disciplinary and that's why we started
the world's fair with with multiple
tracks in 2025 in in New York we talked
about the evolution and the focus on
agent engineering so where where are we
now in sort of June of 2025 Um, that's
where we're going to focus on. I think
we we come a long way regardless like,
you know, we people used to make fun of
AI engineering and and I anticipated
this. We used to be low status. People
just derive GPT rappers and look at all
the GPT rappers. Now all of you are
rich. Um, so we're going to hear from
some of these folks uh in the room. Um,
and uh, thank you for sponsoring as
well.
Um but uh you know I think the other
thing that's also super interesting is
that like you should we the consistent
lesson that we hear is to not over
complicate things from enthropic on the
lat space podcast. Uh we hear we hear we
hear from uh Eric Suns about how they
beat Sweetbench with just a very simple
scaffold. Uh same about deep research
from Greg Brockman who you're going to
hear later on um in the uh sort of
closing keynotes as well as AMP code.
Where's the AMP folks here? AMP amp amp
I think they're probably back in the
other room but um also you know there's
there's a sort of emperor has no clothes
like there's it's still very early fuel
and I think the um AI engineers in the
room like should be very encouraged by
that like there's there's still a lot of
alpha to mind
um if you watch back all the way to the
start of this conference we actually
compared this moment a lot to uh the
time when sort of physics was in was in
full bloom right this is the solve
conference in 1927 when Einstein Mary
Cury and all the other household names
in physics all gathered together And
that's what we're trying to do for this
conference. We've gathered the entire
the best um sort of AI engineers in the
in the world um and and researchers and
and and all that uh to to build and push
the frontier forward. Um the thesis is
that there's this is the time this is
the right time to do it. I said that two
and a half years ago still true still
true today. But I think like there's a
very specific time when like basically
what people did in in that time of the
formation of an industry is that they
set out all the basic ideas that then
lasted for the rest of that industry. So
this is the standard model in physics
and there was a very specific period in
time from like the 40s to the 70s where
they figured it all out and the the next
50 years we haven't really changed the
standard model. So the question that I
want to phrase here is what is the
standard model in AI engineering right
we have standard models in the rest of
engineering right everyone knows ETL
everyone knows MVC everyone knows CRUD
everyone knows map reduce and I've used
those things in like building AI
applications and like it's pretty much
like yes rag is there but I heard rag is
dead I I don't know you guys can tell me
um this day is like long long context
killed rag the other day fine tuning
kills rag I don't know but I I don't
think I definitely don't think is the
full answer. So what other standard
models might emerge to help us guide our
thinking and that's really what I want
to push you guys to. So uh there are a
few candidates standard models and AI
engineering. I'll pick out a few of
these. I I don't have time to talk about
all of them but definitely listen to the
DSP talk from Omar later uh tomorrow.
Um so we're going to cover uh a few of
these. So first is the LM OS. Uh this is
one of the earliest standard standard
models um basically uh from Karpavi in
2023. Um I have updated it for 2025 um
for multimodality for the standard set
of tools that have come out um as well
as um MCP which uh is is has become the
default protocol for connecting with the
outside world. Um second one would be
the LN SDLC software development life
cycle. Um I have two versions of this
one with the intersecting concerns of
all the tooling that you buy. Uh by the
way this is all on the laten space blog
if you want and I'll tweet out the
slides so uh and it's live stream so
whatever um but I think uh for me the
most interesting insight and the aha
moment when I was talking to anker of
brain trust who's going to be keynoting
tomorrow um is that you know the early
parts of the SDLC is are increasingly
commodity right LLM's kind of free you
know um monitoring kind of free and rag
kind of free obviously there's it's just
free tier for all of them and you you
only get start paying but like when you
start to make real money from your
customers is when you start to do evals
and you start to add in security
orchestration and do real work uh that
is real hard engineering work um and I
think that's those are the tracks that
we've added this year um and I'm very
proud to you know I guess push AI
engineering along from demos into
production which is what everyone always
wants another form of standard model is
building effective agents uh our last
conference we had uh Barry one of the
co-authors of building effective agents
from enthopic give an extremely really
popular talk about this. Um I think that
this is now at least the the received
wisdom for how to build an agent. And I
think like that's like that is one
definition. Open AI has a different
definition and I think we're we're
contining to iterate. I think Dominic
yesterday uh released another
improvement on the agents SDK which
builds upon the swarm concept that
OpenAI is pushing.
Um um the way that I approach sort of
the agent standard model has been very
different. So you can refer to my talk
from the previous conference on that. Um
basically trying to do a descriptive u
top down u model of what people use the
words people use to describe agents like
intent um you know control flow um
memory planning and tool use. So there's
all these there's all these like really
really interesting things. But I think
that the thing that really got me um is
like I don't actually use all of that to
build AI news. Um by the way who here
reads AI news? I don't know if there's
like a Yeah. Oh my god, like that's half
of you. Thanks. Uh uh it's it's a really
good tool I built for myself and you
know hopefully uh now over 70,000 people
are reading along as well. Um and the
thing that really got me was Sum
at the last conference. Uh you know he's
the lead of PyTorch and he says he reads
AI news he loves it but it is not an
agent. And I was like what do you mean
it's not an agent? I call it an agent.
You should call it an agent. Um but he's
right. Um, it's actually uh it's
actually I'm going to talk a little bit
about that, but like like why does it
still deliver value even though it's
like a workflow and like you know is
that still interesting to people, right?
Like why do we not brand every single
track here? Voice agents uh you know
like uh like workflow agents, computer
use agents like why is every single
track in this conference not an agent?
Well, I think basically we want to
deliver value instead of arguable
terminology. So the assertion that I
have is that it's really about human
input versus valuable um AI output and
you can sort of make a mental model of
this and track the ratio of this and
that's more interesting than arguing
about definitions of workflow versus
agents. So for example in the copilot
era you had sort of like a debounce
input of like every few characters that
you type then maybe it will do an
autocomplete u in chatbt every few
queries that you type it would maybe
output a responding query. Um it starts
to get more interesting with the
reasoning models with like a 1 to10
ratio and then obviously with like the
new agents now it's like more sort of
deep research notebook. Uh by the way
Ryzen Martin also speaking on the
product uh product management track. Um
she's she's incredible on uh talking
about the story of notebook LM. Um the
other really interesting angle if you
want to take this mental model to the
stretch to stretch it is the zero to one
the ambient agents with no human input.
What kind of interesting uh AI output
can you get? So to me that's that's more
a useful discussion about input versus
output than what is a workflow wise and
an agent how agentic is your thing
versus versus not.
Um talking about AI news uh so you know
it is it is like a bunch of scripts in a
in a in a trench code. Um and I realized
I've written it three times. I've
written it for the Discord scrape. I've
written it for the Reddit scrape. I've
written it for the Twitter scrape. And
basically it's just it's always the same
process. You scrape it. You plan. You
recursively summarize. You format and
you evaluate. Um and and yeah, that's
the three kids in the trench coat. Um
and that's really how what it is. I run
it every day and like we improve it a
little bit, but then I'm also running
this conference. Um so if you generalize
it, that actually starts to become an
interesting model for building AI
intensive applications where you start
to make thousands of AI calls to serve
serve a particular purpose. Um so you
sync you plan and and you sort of
parallel process you analyze and sort of
reduce that down to uh from from many to
one and then you uh deliver uh deliver
the contents um to the to the user and
then you evaluate and to me like that
conveniently forms an acronym SP AD um
which is which is really nice. There's
also sort of interesting AI engineering
elements that are that are fit in there.
So you can process all these into a
knowledge graph. you can um turn these
into like structured outputs and you can
generate code as well. So for example um
you know chat GBT with canvas or cloud
with um artifacts is a way of just
delivering the output as a code artifact
instead of just uh text output and I
think it's like a really interesting way
to think about this. So this is my
mental model so far. Um I I wish I had
the space to go into it but ask me
later. This is what I'm developing right
now. I think what I what I would really
emphasize is, you know, I think like
there's all sorts of interesting ways to
think about what the standard model is
and whether it's useful for you in in
taking your application to the next step
of like how do I add more intelligence
to this in in a way that's useful and
not annoying. Uh, and for me, this is
it. Okay. So, I've I've thrown a bunch
of standard models in here, but that's
just my current hypothesis. I want you
at this conference when in all your
conversations with each other and with
the speakers to think about what the new
standard model for AI engineering is.
What can everyone use to improve their
applications and I guess ultimately
build products that people want to use
which is what Lori uh mentioned at the
start. So um I'm really excited about
this conference. It's so it's been such
an honor and a joy to get it together
for you guys and I hope you enjoy the
rest of the conference. Thank you so
much.
[Music]